- Maligayang pagbabalik sa "Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation." Ako si John Watrous, at ako ang Technical Director
para sa IBM Quantum Education.
Ito ang ikalimang aralin ng serye, at ito ang unang aralin sa
ikalawang yunit ng serye, na tungkol sa Quantum Algorithms.
Sa yunit na ito, susuriin natin
ang mga computational na kalamangan ng quantum information, ibig sabihin, titingnan natin
kung ano ang magagawa natin
sa quantum computers at ang mga kalamangan na maaaring
mayroon ang quantum computers kumpara sa classical computers.
Magtutuon tayo sa kung ano ang magagawa natin sa isang quantum computer kaysa sa isang distributed
na setting, halimbawa,
kung saan maraming quantum computers ang nagkakainteraksyon sa pamamagitan ng isang network.
Mayroon nga, sa katotohanan, mga quantum na kalamangan na mahahanap sa distributed na mga setting, kung saan ang komunikasyon at
cryptography ay may papel,
pero hindi tayo mag-uusap
tungkol sa mga bagay na iyon sa yunit na ito.
Ang yunit na ito ay tungkol sa mga quantum algorithm na tumatakbo sa mga solong quantum computer.
Magsimula tayo sa isang natural na tanong. Ano ang mga kalamangan na maaaring
maibigay ng isang quantum computer?
Ang pangunahing isa ay maaaring makapagbigay ang mga quantum computer ng mas mabilis na solusyon sa ilang computational na problema.
Mahalaga ang oras, at kahit na ang mga computer na
ginagamit natin araw-araw ay medyo mabilis, napakabagal pa rin nila
para malutas ang ilang partikular na computational na problema dahil lang sa likas na
computational na kahirapan ng mga problemang iyon.
Ang potensyal na ito na maaaring pahintulutan tayo ng mga quantum computer na malutas ang mga problema na
masyadong mabagal para sa mga classical computer
ay talagang nagsisilbing
pangunahing puwersang nagtutulak sa pananaliksik sa quantum algorithms sa nakaraang ilang dekada.
Mayroon pang ibang mga computational
na mapagkukunan bukod sa oras na maaaring isaalang-alang, tulad ng dami ng memorya ng computer na kailangan para sa mga kalkulasyon,
pero hindi masyadong makakatipid ang mga quantum computer
pagdating sa memorya, kung tutuusin, at ang memorya ng classical computer
ay medyo mura
lalo na kumpara sa quantum na memorya. Kaya wala talagang
masyadong pangako dito.
Maaari rin nating isipin ang iba pang mga mapagkukunan tulad ng dami ng enerhiya
na kailangan para sa kalkulasyon, pero hindi ka talaga
kailangan ng masyadong maraming enerhiya
para mag-compute nang klasikal, lalo na kung ikaw ay
handang pabagalin ang mga bagay.
Kaya talagang ang oras
na kailangan para sa mga kalkulasyon ang ating pangunahing pokus.
Narito ang isang pangkalahatang-ideya para sa aralin, na tungkol sa isang partikular na
modelo ng kalkulasyon na kilala bilang ang query model.
Maaari mong isipin ang modelong ito bilang parang isang Petri dish para sa pagbuo ng mga algorithmic na ideya, parehong quantum at klasikal.
Hindi ito nilalayon na maging isang praktikal na modelo na naglalarawan ng uri ng
mga computational na problema na nararanasan natin sa totoong buhay.
Lilipat tayo mula sa query model sa mga susunod na aralin ng yunit na ito at magtutuon sa halip sa mga modelo na hinihimok ng mas praktikal
na mga konsepto ng kalkulasyon,
pero ang query model ay isang
napakagandang lugar para magsimula.
Ito ay isang simpleng modelo na nagpapahintulot sa atin na tuklasin ang
potensyal ng mga quantum computer nang walang maraming teknikal
na detalye na humahadlang,
at nagbibigay-daan din ito sa atin na ihiwalay ang ilan sa mga
talagang mahahalagang ideya sa likod ng quantum computing at kung paano ito gumagana.
Ang quantum computing ay, sa katotohanan, unang nabuo sa loob ng modelong ito, at ang mga ideyang
nabuo sa loob nito ay direktang nagbigay-inspirasyon sa
mahahalagang quantum algorithm
tulad ng Shor's algorithm para sa factoring.
Sa unang seksyon ng aralin, titingnan natin nang partikular kung ano ang query model of computation,
at sa ikalawa, ikatlo,
at ikaapat na mga seksyon, tatalakayin natin ang tatlong
quantum query algorithm, katulad ng Deutsch's algorithm,
ang Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm,
at Simon's algorithm, na nagpapakita ng dumaraming
kahanga-hangang mga kalamangan
ng mga quantum computer
kumpara sa mga classical computer sa loob ng query model of computation.
Para ipaliwanag ang query model of computation, magsimula muna tayo sa isang mas karaniwang
abstraksiyon ng kalkulasyon.
Narito ang isang larawan na
kumakatawan sa isang kalkulasyon sa napaka-simple at pangunahing mga termino.
Mayroon tayong input, na karaniwang tumatagal sa
anyo ng isang binary string, kahit na maaari tayong gumamit ng iba pang
mga simbolo kung gusto natin.
Ang input ay ibinibigay sa kalkulasyon, na kinakatawan ng isang asul na
parihaba sa larawang ito,
at ang resulta ng kalkulasyon ay ang paglikha ng ilang output, at muli, iyon ay kadalasang
isang binary string.
Siyempre, ang larawang ito
ay hindi talaga partikular tungkol sa kung paano gumagana ang kalkulasyon mismo.
Maaari tayong bumuo ng iba't ibang
partikular na computational na modelo para gawin iyon, tulad ng mga Turing machine
at Boolean circuit,
o quantum circuit kung nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa
quantum computation.
Totoo na ang larawang ito
ay hindi kumakatawan sa katotohanan na marami sa mga
computer na ginagamit natin araw-araw ay patuloy na tumatanggap ng
input at gumagawa ng output,
sa esensya ay nakikipag-ugnayan sa atin at sa iba pang mga computer sa pamamagitan ng
internet, halimbawa.
Pero hindi tayo sinisikap na katawanin
ang mga interaksyong iyon dito.
Ito ay tungkol sa pag-modelo ng
mga nakahiwalay na computational na gawain.
Halimbawa, ang input ay maaaring ang
binary encoding ng isang numero o isang representasyon ng isang matrix
o isang paglalarawan ng isang molekula o talagang anumang bagay na nasa isip natin, at mayroong ilang computational na gawain
na ginagawa sa input na iyon lamang.
Ang pangunahing punto dito ay
na ang buong input ay ibinibigay sa kalkulasyon, at walang tungkol sa
input ang nakatago mula rito.
Ang query model of
computation ay gumagana nang iba.
Sa query model, ang input ay ginagawang available
sa anyo ng isang function na maaaring ma-access ng kalkulasyon sa pamamagitan ng paggawa ng mga query,
o sa ibang salita, sa pamamagitan ng pag-evaluate ng function
sa iba't ibang input.
Dito makikita mo na iyon na kinakatawan
sa anyo ng isang larawan.
Katulad ng dati, ang kalkulasyon ay kinakatawan
ng isang asul na parihaba, pero sa halip na direktang makatanggap ng input
sa anyo ng isang string
ng mga bit, halimbawa, ina-access nito ang input sa pamamagitan ng epektibong pagtatanong
at pagtanggap ng mga sagot.
Minsan ginagamit natin ang mga
terminong oracle at black box para sumangguni sa mekanismo
na nagbibigay ng input.
Mayroong pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng
isang oracle at isang black box sa complexity theory, pero hindi iyon magiging relevant para sa mga layunin ng talakayan na ito.
Anyway, ang mga terminong ito ay nilalayon
na ihatid ang pangunahing ideya.
Sa sinaunang Gresya, maaari kang
pumunta sa isang oracle, tulad ng Oracle at Delphi,
at magtanong ng isang mahalagang tanong,
at sasagutin ng oracle ang
partikular na tanong na iyon, pero tiyak na hindi niya sasabihin sa iyo ang lahat ng alam niya.
Sa magkaparehong paraan, kapag
nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa isang black box, naiisip natin ang ilang
uri ng proseso o sistema
kung saan maaari tayong pumili kung ano ang papasok at maaari tayong makita kung ano ang lalabas, pero wala tayong anumang pag-unawa
sa panloob nitong mekanismo.
At iyon ang kaso dito. Ang input sa problema
ay nasa anyo ng isang function, at ang tanging magagawa natin ay
ang i-evaluate ang function na iyon,
pero kung hindi man, wala tayong
anumang kaalaman o pag-unawa sa kung paano ito gumagana.
Sa buong aralin,
ilalaan natin ang titik f para sa function na
kumakatawan sa input, at gagawa tayo ng pagpapalagay
na palagi itong nasa
anyo na makikita mo dito.
Ang Sigma ay kumakatawan sa binary alphabet, kaya ang f ay isang function mula sa mga string
ng mga bit patungo sa mga string ng mga bit,
at partikular, ipapalagay natin
na ang input sa f ay isang string ng mga bit na may haba n, at ang output ay isang string
ng mga bit na may haba m,
kung saan ang n at m ay mga positibong integer.
Para sa iba't ibang problema, magkakaroon tayo
ng mga paghihigpit sa n at m, pero sa lahat ng kaso, ang input function ay
magtataglay ng ganitong anyo.
Kapag sinasabi nating ang isang
kalkulasyon ay gumagawa ng isang query, ang ibig sabihin natin ay ang
function na f ay ine-evaluate nang isang beses,
ibig sabihin, isang string x na may haba N ang pinipili ng kalkulasyon, at ang string f ng x ay
ginagawang available sa kanya
ng oracle o ng black box. At sa wakas, ang napakasimpleng paraan na susukatin natin ang computational cost
ng isang query algorithm ay ang bibilangin kung ilang query ang kailangan nito.
Kaya, kahit na totoo na
talagang pinaka-interesado tayo sa kung gaano katagal tumatagal ang mga kalkulasyon, kapag pinag-aaralan natin ang query model,
karaniwang pinapanatili natin ang mga bagay na
simple at bibilangin lang ang mga query, at iyon ang gagawin natin sa araling ito.
Ngayon, tingnan natin ang ilang
mga halimbawa ng mga query problem, ibig sabihin ang mga computational
na problema sa query model,
at dito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ilalarawan ko lang
ang mga problema mismo, at sa puntong ito, hindi ako magsasabi ng anumang bagay
tungkol sa kung paano solusonahin ang mga ito.
Ang unang problema ay ang OR problem.
Sa kasong ito, ang input ay isang function
mula sa n bits patungo sa 1 bit lamang, kaya ang m ay katumbas ng 1 para sa problemang ito,
at ang kinakailangang output para sa
problema ay alinman sa 1 o 0.
Kung mayroong ilang n bits string x kung saan ang f ng x ay katumbas ng 1, kung gayon ang tamang sagot ay 1,
at kung hindi man, kung ang f ng x ay
palaging 0 para sa bawat string x, kung gayon ang tamang sagot ay 0.
Kaya kung iniisip natin ang function na f bilang nagbibigay sa atin ng random
na access sa dalawa sa n bits, isa para sa bawat n bit string x,
kung gayon ang tinatanong nito
ay ang OR ng mga bit na iyon, at iyan ang dahilan kung bakit ito ay tinatawag na OR problem.
Ang isa pang halimbawa ay ang parity problem, na katulad ng OR problem maliban sa nagtatanong ito ng parity,
o sa ibang salita, ang eXclusive OR ng lahat ng single-bit
na output value ng function.
Ang isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi nito ay
na ang tamang sagot ay 0 kung ang bilang ng n bits string x kung saan ang f ng x ay katumbas ng 1 ay pantay,
at ang tamang sagot ay
1 kung ang bilang na iyon ay gansal.
Ang isang halimbawa ng isang problema kung saan ang m ay hindi necessarily katumbas ng 1 ay ang minimum problem.
Dito, ang function na f ay nasa karaniwang anyo, at walang mga paghihigpit sa n at m,
at ang tamang sagot ay anumang output value
ng function na unang darating sa lexicographic
o dictionary ordering
ng mga binary string. Bilang alternatibo, kung gusto mong
isipin ang mga string ng haba m bilang kumakatawan sa mga di-negatibong
integer sa binary notation,
kung gayon ang tamang sagot
ay ang pinakamaliit na posible o minimum na halaga na
lumalabas mula sa function na ito.
Minsan isinasaalang-alang din natin ang mga query problem kung saan mayroon tayong isang pangako
sa input function, o sa ibang salita, ilang
uri ng garantiya rito,
at hindi tayo nag-aalala tungkol sa mga function na hindi nakakatugon sa pangakong iyon.
Ang mga function na hindi nakakatugon sa pangako ay itinuturing bilang mga "don't care" na input.
At hindi tayo responsable sa kung ano ang mangyayari sa mga input na iyon.
Narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang query problem na may pangako na tinatawag na unique search.
Ito ay may kaugnayan sa OR
problem, pero ito ay iba.
Ang input function ay may parehong
anyo tulad ng para sa OR problem, na kumuukuha ng
n bits string patungo sa mga bit.
Sa pagkakataong ito, ipinangako sa atin na
mayroon nang eksakto isang string Z na nagdudulot sa f na mag-evaluate sa 1,
na ang f ng x ay katumbas ng 0
para sa bawat string x maliban sa z, at ang tamang output
ay ang natatanging string z na ito.
Siyempre, mayroong mga
pagpipilian para sa function na f na hindi nakakatugon sa kondisyong ito, pero hindi tayo naglalagay ng anumang kinakailangan
sa mga algorithm para sa problemang ito kapag binibigyan sila ng gayong
mga function bilang input.
Nagmamalasakit lang tayo tungkol sa mga function na nakakatugon sa pangako.
Ngayon, lahat ng apat na
mga problema na binanggit ko ay medyo natural na mga problema, ibig sabihin madaling ipaliwanag ang mga ito,
at madaling isipin ang mga sitwasyon kung saan maaaring lumitaw ang pangangailangan na malutas ang mga ito, pero ang ilang query problem
ay hindi ganito.
Sa katotohanan, minsan isinasaalang-alang natin ang mga napaka-
contrived na query problem, kung saan mahirap isipin na may sinuman na
talagang gustong malutas ang mga ito.
Ang Simon's problem, na makikita natin
sa ibang pagkakataon sa aralin, ay medyo napapailalim sa kategoryang ito, pero mayroon pang iba
na mas malala sa ilang paraan, pero sila, sa kabila nito, ay talagang nagiging medyo mahalaga sa pag-aaral ng query model.
Hindi natin pinag-aaralan ang mga problemang ito dahil necessarily gustong
malutas ang mga ito sa practice.
Ang paraan ng pag-iisip mo rito ay naghahanap tayo ng
mga sukdulan ng iba't ibang uri,
partikular, kapag nagtatrabaho tayo sa loob ng
Petri dish ng modelong ito, isang natural na paraan para tuklasin
ang mga quantum algorithmic na ideya
ay ang bumuo ng mga lubos na contrived na problema, kung saan maaari nating pinakamahusay na pagsamantalahan ang
kapangyarihan ng mga quantum computer.
At maaari itong talagang
magbigay ng malaking liwanag sa kung paano maaaring maging kapaki-pakinabang ang mga quantum computer sa mas praktikal na mga setting.
Maaari nating pormal na tukuyin ang konsepto
ng isang query sa iba't ibang paraan depende sa kung anong computational
na modelo ang ginagamit natin.
Halimbawa, sa Turing
machine model of computation, na hindi natin pinag-usapan at hindi natin tatalakayin sa seryeng ito,
mayroong isang tiyak na paraan ng
pag-pormal sa konsepto ng isang query na makatuwirang para sa modelong iyon.
Para sa mga circuit model, nagtatakda tayo ng mga espesyal na uri ng
gate na tinatawag na query gate, at iyon ang paraan ng pormal na representasyon ng mga query.
Para sa mga Boolean circuit, mayroong isang napakasimpleng paraan ng paggawa nito, na simpleng isipin na mayroon tayong mga query gate
na direktang nag-e-evaluate ng input function, tulad ng makikita mo dito sa screen.
Ang ideya ay maaari tayong
gumamit ng mga query gate na ito para bumuo ng mga circuit na naglulutas ng anumang
problema na tinitingnan natin,
at para gumana nang tama, ang mga circuit ay kailangang magbigay ng tamang sagot para sa anumang input function f na ibinibigay,
ipinagpapalagay na nakakatugon ito sa pangako sa kaso ng isang promise problem.
Narito ang isang simpleng halimbawa
ng isang Boolean circuit na naglulutas ng parity
problem kapag ang n ay katumbas ng 1,
kaya ang input function na f ay mula sa
1 bit patungo sa 1 bit sa kasong ito.
Ang ginagawa ng circuit na ito ay ang pag-evaluate ng function
f sa mga input na 0 at 1 gamit ang dalawang query gate na ito.
Pagkatapos ay ini-plug nito ang dalawang output value na
nakuha nito mula sa mga query gate sa Boolean circuit mula sa aralin tatlo na nagku-compute ng XOR,
na kapareho ng parity.
Para maging malinaw, ang dalawang
input value na ito dito ay hindi mga input sa problema,
ibig sabihin ang parity problem,
kapag nagtatrabaho tayo sa query model, ang input sa problema
ay ang function na f, at dapat mong isipin ang dalawang
input na ito sa circuit
bilang mga hard-coded
na halaga na hindi nagbabago, sila ay essentially bahagi ng algorithm.
Gusto naming i-compute ang XOR ng f 0 at f 1, kaya ini-initialize natin ang dalawang
wire na ito sa ganitong paraan
para gumana ito. Gumamit tayo ng dalawang query gate
dito, ang isa at ang isa pa,
at kaya ang algorithm na kinakatawan
ng Boolean circuit na ito ay gumagawa ng dalawang query, at kung nag-iisip tayo tungkol sa
parity problem sandali
para sa mga function mula sa isang bit patungo sa isang bit, nakikita natin na ito ay ganap na kinakailangan para sa anumang Boolean circuit
na naglulutas ng problemang ito
na gumawa ng hindi bababa sa dalawang query.
Kung isa lang ang query mo para alam mo lang ang isang
output value ng function na f at hindi ang isa pa, wala ka talagang
anumang impormasyon
tungkol sa parity, dahil ang isa pang output value
ay maaaring maging 0 o 1 nang pantay-pantay, na humahantong sa alinman sa
dalawang posibleng solusyon
sa problema. Kaya sa mga tuntunin ng bilang
ng mga query na ginagawa nito, ang Boolean circuit na ito ay kasing ganda ng maaaring mangyari
para sa parity problem
kapag ang n ay katumbas ng 1.
Mayroong isa pang punto tungkol sa mga query gate na sulit banggitin bago tayo magpatuloy, at iyon ay kapag nagdidisenyo at nagsusuri tayo ng mga query algorithm,
hindi tayo nag-aalala kahit kaano tungkol sa kung paano
isinasagawa ang mga query gate.
Ipinapalagay na ang mga
query gate na ito ay ibinibigay sa atin, at ang kahirapan ng pagtatayo ng
mga ito ay hindi na ang ating alalahanin.
Maaari mong isipin ang mga
query gate mismo bilang ang input kung gusto mo, at hindi ito ang ating trabaho na gawin ang input, sinisikap lang nating
malutas ang isang partikular na problema
na binibigyan ng input. Siyempre, kapag ang f ay isang function
mula sa isang bit patungo sa isang bit, may apat lang na posibleng pagpipilian,
at madali na
i-implement ang alinman sa mga ito, pero sa pangkalahatan, para sa mga function
na may maraming input bit,
maaaring maging napakahirap na i-implement ang mga query gate
para sa mga function na iyon.
Para maging malinaw, hindi ito
nangangahulugang ang isyu kung paano isinasagawa ang mga query gate ay hindi mahalaga, kundi sa halip na hindi ito isinasaalang-alang
bilang bahagi ng cost
ng isang query algorithm.
Ito ay naaayon sa ideya na hindi talaga ito
tungkol sa praktikal na computing o talagang pagtatayo ng mga circuit per se,
ito ay tungkol sa pagtatrabaho sa loob ng
isang theoretical na balangkas na nagsasabi sa atin ng mga kawili-wiling
bagay tungkol sa kalkulasyon.
Magkakaroon tayo ng mas maraming sasabihin tungkol rito kapag ginawa natin ang tumalon mula sa modelong ito patungo sa isang mas karaniwang modelo ng kalkulasyon, at iyon ang pangunahing paksa ng susunod na aralin,
Aralin 6.
Ngayon ipalit natin ang ating pansin
sa mga quantum circuit.
Para sa mga quantum circuit, babaguhin natin ang
kahulugan ng mga query gate para gawing unitary ang mga ito.
Gusto nating magawa
ang mga query sa loob ng mga quantum circuit at para sila ay gumana nang
linearly sa mga quantum state
para epektibo tayong
makakagawa ng mga query sa super position.
Maaaring mukhang inililipat natin
ang goalposts, para sabihin, sa pamamagitan ng pagbabago ng kahulugan ng query kumpara sa kung ano ang nakita natin para sa mga Boolean circuit,
pero mayroon itong justipikasyon na tatalakayin natin nang mas
detalyado sa susunod na aralin.
Sa ngayon, ito ay isang kahulugan lamang.
Partikular, ang
kahulugan ay ang sumusunod, na binibigyan ng anumang function f ng
parehong anyo tulad ng dati,
ibig sabihin nag-map ito mula sa n bits
string patungo sa m bits string, ang query gate Uf ay gumagana sa n + m qubit
at tinukuyin ng
aksyon na inilarawan dito sa mga standard basis state.
Makikita natin ang isang figure
na kumakatawan sa kahulugang ito sa sandali lang, pero una, hayaan ninyong gawing malinaw ang notation
na ginagamit dito,
at iyon ay tuwing ginagamit natin
ang simbolo para sa XOR bilang isang operasyon sa pagitan ng dalawang
string ng parehong haba,
tinutukoy natin ang
bitwise eXclusive OR, at dito makikita mo ang isang halimbawa.
Sa kahulugan, parehong ang y at f ng
x ay mga string ng haba m, kaya ang string na ito dito
kumakatawan sa string na nakuha natin
sa pamamagitan ng pag-XOR ng dalawang string na iyon
nang magkasama, isang bit sa isang pagkakataon, at narito ang diagram
na nagpapaliwanag kung paano gumagana ang mga gate na ito.
Ang tuktok na n qubit ay katumbas ng
argumento ng function.
At kapag nagsimula sila
sa isang standard basis state, cat x sa diagram na ito, ang standard basis state na iyon
ay dumaraan nang walang pagbabago
at nire-echo bilang bahagi ng output.
Ang ibabang m qubit ay katumbas ng output
ng function na f, at kapag nagsimula sila
sa anumang standard basis state,
cat y sa diagram na ito, ang nangyayari ay ang
output ng function na f ng x ay nai-XOR sa string y.
Ito ang nangyayari para sa
mga standard basis state, at kung gusto nating malaman
kung ano ang nangyayari sa pangkalahatan para sa iba pang quantum state, ginagamit natin ang linearity, tulad ng palagi nating ginagawa.
Isang dahilan para tukuyin ang mga query gate tulad nito kung saan ine-echo natin ang input at ginagamit natin ang bitwise XOR para sa output
ay na ang mga gate na ito ay palaging unitary para sa anumang pagpipilian ng function na f.
Ito ay, sa katotohanan, isang
deterministic na operasyon.
At kung ipahayag natin ito bilang isang matrix para sa anumang pagpipilian ng isang function na F, makakakuha tayo ng isang permutation matrix,
ibig sabihin ang isa na may isang solong isa sa bawat row at sa bawat column, at lahat ng iba pang entry ay katumbas ng 0.
At ang mga permutation matrix
ay palaging unitary.
Sa katunayan, para sa operasyong ito, makukuha natin na ang operasyon
ay sarili nitong inverse, kaya ang Uf dager ay katumbas ng Uf.
Kung ang gusto lang nating gawin sa mga
gate na ito ay mag-evaluate ng f ng x para sa ilang string x, madali iyon,
itakda lang natin ang y bilang
ang all-zero string. Kaya kapag kinuha natin ang XOR ng bit y, matitira lang tayo sa f ng x.
Dito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, makikita mo ang notation na ginagamit para tukuyin ang all-zero string.
Ito ay mukhang tulad ng 0 sa kapangyarihan ng M, pero hindi iyon ang ibig sabihin nito.
Ibig sabihin nito ang string ng mga zero
na may haba na katumbas ng M.
Kapag pinag-uusapan natin ang
mga string kumpara sa mga numero, ang mga exponent ay karaniwang nangangahulugang inuulit natin ang string na iyon
ng ilang beses,
kaya ito ay 0 na paulit-ulit ng m beses.
Ito ay isang maginhawa at tumpak na paraan lamang ng paglalarawan ng string na ito.
Muli, kapag nagtatrabaho tayo
sa query model, hindi tayo nag-aalala tungkol sa kung paano
i-implement ang mga query gate na ito.
Iyon ay parehong isyu
na mayroon tayo sa mga query gate para sa Boolean circuit.
Hindi ang ating trabaho na ihanda ang input, binibigyan tayo ng input sa
anyo ng mga query gate na ito.
Ituturo ko lang, gayunpaman, na kung alam natin kung paano
i-implement ang function na f gamit ang isang Boolean circuit, posible na
i-translate ang implementasyong iyon
nang direkta patungo sa isang quantum
circuit na implementasyon ng Uf, at makikita natin nang eksakto kung paano
gumagana iyon sa susunod na aralin.
Bilang isang aside, medyo simple na gumawa ng isang Boolean circuit
na gumagana tulad nito, gamit ang isang solong klasikal
na query gate para sa function na f,
pero iyon ay medyo iba sa pagkakaroon ng isang quantum
circuit na implementasyon ng unitary gate na ito.
Ang punto, gayunpaman, ay na
para sa mga klasikal na query algorithm, ang pagkakaroon ng isang query gate na gumagana tulad nito ay, sa katunayan, katumbas
ng pagkakaroon ng isang ordinaryong
klasikal na query gate para sa f, sa kahulugang maaaring i-implement ang alinman sa isa gamit ang isa pa.
Sa seksyong ito ng aralin, tatalakayin natin ang Deutsch's algorithm, na isang napakasimpleng
quantum query algorithm, pero ito ay talagang isang hiyas.
Ang algorithm na ito ay nagmula sa isang papel noong 1985 na isinulat ni David Deutsch, na isa sa mga pinakaunang tao na nagtatrabaho sa theoretical
na mga pundasyon ng quantum computing.
Ang algorithm mismo ay kumakatawan sa isang napakamaliit na bahagi
ng papel ni Deutsch noong 1985, at sa katunayan,
ang algorithm na tinatawag natin ngayon
na Deutsch's algorithm ay talagang isang pinahusay na bersyon ng algorithm na inilarawan ni Deutsch.
Nagbibigay ito ng isang napakamaliit na halimbawa kung paano maaaring
mag-alok ng mga computational na kalamangan ang mga quantum computer, pero kailangan kang magsimula sa isang lugar,
at talagang ito ay isang mahalagang spark na nagsimula ng mga bagay.
Ang Deutsch's algorithm ay naglulutas ng isang query problem na madalas na tinatawag na Deutsch's problem sa konteksto ng quantum computing,
pero sa katunayan, wala itong iba
kundi ang parity problem para sa mga function mula sa isang bit patungo sa isang bit, na napag-usapan na natin.
Tulad ng nakita na natin, mayroong apat na function
mula sa isang bit patungo sa isang bit, at inilarawan ang mga ito dito sa screen sa pamamagitan ng kanilang mga talahanayan ng mga halaga.
Ang una at huli sa mga function na ito
ay constant, habang ang gitnang dalawa ay balanced sa kahulugang ang dalawang
posibleng output value
ay lumilitaw nang parehong bilang ng beses.
Para sa dalawang constant na function,
nakikita natin na ang parity, o sa ibang salita, ang eXclusive OR ng dalawang output ay 0,
at para sa dalawang balanced na function, ang parity ng mga output ay 1.
Kaya ang isang katumbas na paraan para
ilarawan ang parity problem sa partikular na kasong ito, kung saan ang function na f ay tumatagal ng
isang solong bit bilang input,
o sa ibang salita, ang Deutsch's problem, ay tulad ng makikita mo dito.
Ang input ay isang function na f
mula sa isang bit patungo sa isang bit, at ang output ay 0 kung ang f ay constant
at 1 kung ang f ay balanced.
Tulad ng iminungkahi ko na, bawat klasikal na query algorithm
na naglulutas ng problemang ito ay kailangang gumawa ng hindi bababa sa dalawang query sa f.
Kung matututo ka lang ng isa sa
dalawang output value ng f, wala ka pa ring anumang impormasyon tungkol sa parity ng dalawang output.
At ito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ay totoo
kahit para sa mga klasikal na algorithm na gumagamit ng randomness.
Ang randomness ay maaaring maging napaka-kapaki-pakinabang minsan para sa paglulutas ng mga query problem, at makikita natin ang isang halimbawa
medyo mamaya sa aralin,
pero ang randomness ay hindi nakakatulong dito.
Kaya ang ating algorithm mula kanina ay optimal sa mga klasikal na query algorithm
para sa Deutsch's problem.
Ngayon ay titingnan natin
ang Deutsche's algorithm, na isang quantum query algorithm na naglulutas ng Deutsch's
problem gamit ang isang solong query.
At narito ang algorithm
na inilarawan bilang isang quantum circuit.
Mayroon tayong dalawang qubit
na ini-initialize tulad ng makikita mo dito, na ang tuktok ay ini-initialize sa cat 0 at ang ibaba ay ini-initialize sa cat 1,
at makikita natin kung bakit ini-initialize natin ang mga qubit na ito tulad nito sa ilang sandali.
Nagpapatunaw tayo ng Hadamard
gate sa dalawang qubit, pinasok ang mga ito sa query gate, nagpapatunaw ng isa pang Hadamard
gate sa tuktok na qubit,
at pagkatapos ay sinusukat ito. At ang claim ay
na ang measurement outcome ay nagbibigay sa atin, nang may katiyakan, ng
tamang sagot sa problema.
Kaya suriin natin ang
circuit nang isa-isang hakbang para makita nang eksakto kung paano ito gumagana.
Ang estado ng dalawang qubit pagkatapos ng unang layer ng Hadamard gate ay ang tensor product ng
minus at plus na mga estado.
Ang Hadamard sa itaas ay nag-map ng
0 state patungo sa isang plus state, at ang Hadamard sa ibaba ay nag-map ng 1 state patungo sa isang minus state.
Ang tuktok na qubit ay nasa kanan, at ang ibabang qubit ay nasa kaliwa, kaya ito ang estado na nakuha natin.
Napakahalagang ang ibabang qubit ay nasa minus state, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, hindi ito gagana kung ini-initialize natin ang ibabang qubit
sa isang 0 state sa halip na isang 1 state.
Ipo-palawakin natin ang estado na ito
sa kalahati, tulad ng makikita mo dito.
Ang dahilan para gawin iyon
ay hindi malinaw sa puntong ito, pero ito ay magiging maginhawa
sa ilang sandali lang.
Susunod, isipin natin tungkol sa
estado ng dalawang qubit pagkatapos maisagawa ang query gate.
Ang paraan ng paggana ng query gate
ay kinokompute nito ang F sa standard basis
state ng tuktok na qubit at inaalis ang halaga
sa ibabang qubit,
at dito makikita natin ang
resulta ng paggawa nito.
Para sa unang termino, ang standard basis state
ng tuktok na qubit ay 0, kaya ang f ng zero ay nai-XOR
sa ibabang qubit,
at gumagana iyon sa pamamagitan ng linearity. At katulad ito para sa ikalawang termino, maliban na ang standard basis state
para sa tuktok na qubit ay 1, kaya inaalis natin ang f ng 1 sa ibabang qubit.
At sa puntong ito, maaari
nating gawing simple ang expression na ito sa pamamagitan ng pagmamasid sa formula
na makikita mo sa ibaba dito, na gumagana kapag ang a ay alinman sa 0 o 1.
At maaari nating suriin ito para sa dalawang halagang iyon nang hiwalay.
Kung ang a ay katumbas ng 0, kung gayon
ang pag-XOR sa a ay walang ginagawa, at ang negatibong 1 sa kapangyarihan ng 0 ay 1,
kaya ang dalawang panig ay pantay. At kung ang a ay katumbas ng 1, nakuha natin ang cat 1 minus cat
0 kapag kinuha natin ang XOR,
na siyang negatibong 1
beses ang cat 0 minus cat 1.
At kung gagamitin natin ang formula na iyon
para gawing simple ang ating estado, kung saan kinukuha natin ang a na katumbas
ng f ng 0 sa kaliwa at ang a ay katumbas ng f ng 1 sa kanan,
makukuha natin ang expression
na makikita mo dito.
Kaya kapag inihambing natin ang dalawang
quantum state vector na π1 at π2, nakikita natin na ang ginagawa ng Uf gate
ay epektibong inilalagay ang
isa sa dalawang halaga, f ng 0 o f ng 1, sa
exponent ng negatibong 1,
o sa ibang salita, sa
phase ng bawat termino.
Ito ang dahilan para sa
pag-initialize ng ibabang qubit sa 1 at pagsasagawa ng isang Hadamard gate dito para gumawa ng minus state,
na nagpapahintulot na mangyari ito.
Ito ay tinatawag na phase kickback na penomenon, at babalikan natin ito sa ilang sandali para tingnan ito mula sa isa pang anggulo.
Medyo mahalaga ito, at makikita natin itong nangyayari nang ilang
beses pa sa aralin, pati na rin sa mga susunod na aralin.
Maaari na tayong gawing simple sa pamamagitan ng pag-pull
ng minus state pabalik sa labas para makuha ang expression
na makikita mo dito.
Bilang isang aside, medyo kawili-wili na
mapansin na walang talagang
anumang entanglement dito.
Parehong mga estado na ito ay product state. Kaya, buweno, ang entanglement
ay lubhang kawili-wili,
ay hindi nangyayari na
gumaganap ng anumang papel sa partikular na algorithm na ito.
Linisin natin ito nang kaunti para magkaroon tayo ng kaunti pang espasyo.
Ang maaari na nating gawin ngayon ay
mag-pull ng isang factor ng negatibong 1 na itinaas sa kapangyarihan ng f ng zero sa labas
para makuha ang expression ng
estado na makikita mo dito.
Mapapansin mong dito, mayroon tayong eXclusive OR ng f 0 at f 1 sa exponent ng negatibong 1.
Maaaring inaasahan natin na ito ay
f ng 1 minus f ng 0 dahil na-pull natin ang factor ng negatibong 1 sa kapangyarihan ng f ng 0 palabas,
pero makukuha natin ang parehong
halaga kung kukuha tayo ng XOR dahil ang mga ito ay mga bit, at ang tanging bagay na mahalaga kapag mayroon tayong isang integer sa
exponent ng negatibong 1
ay kung ang integer na iyon ay pantay o gansal.
Ang isa pang paraan para ipahayag ang
estado na ito ay tulad ng mayroon tayo dito, kung saan isinasaalang-alang lang natin
ang dalawang posibleng kaso para sa XOR.
at iyon ay isang maginhawang
paraan para ipahayag ang estado habang isinasaalang-alang natin ang aksyon
ng huling Hadamard gate kasama ang measurement.
Kapag isasagawa natin ang huling
Hadamard gate sa tuktok na qubit, ang plus state ay
nababago sa isang 0 state
at ang minus state ay
nababago sa isang 1 state, na maaaring isulat nang mas maigsi tulad nito.
At sa wakas, kapag
isinasagawa ang measurement, ang resulta na nakuha natin ay
ang XOR ng f 0 at f 1,
na siyang halagang hinahanap natin, at ganoon gumagana ang Deutsch's algorithm.
Medyo simple ito, at kung tatanungin natin ang ating sarili kung ano
ang nagpapagana nito, na nagpapahintulot sa atin na i-compute
ang parity ng dalawang bit
sa isang solong query kaysa sa dalawa, ang isang makatwirang sagot ay
ang interference.
Epektibo tayong
nag-co-compute ng f ng 0 at f ng 1 nang sabay, dahil una nating isasagawa
ang Hadamard gate
sa tuktok na qubit para ilagay ang input sa f sa
isang super position ng 0 at 1.
At sa pamamagitan ng phase kickback kasama ang huling Hadamard gate, tayo ay essentially gumagawa ng
constructive interference
para sa tamang sagot at destructive interference
para sa maling sagot.
Kaya hindi natin nakikita ang maling sagot, nakikita lang natin ang tamang sagot.
Hayaan ninyong sabihin ko na ngayon ang kaunti pa tungkol sa phase kickback na penomenon para makita ito mula sa
medyo ibang anggulo.
Una, obserbahan natin
ang napakasimpleng formula na ito kung saan ang b at c ay mga arbitrary na binary na halaga.
Sa maikling salita, ang pag-XOR ng isang bit b sa pamamagitan ng halaga 1 ay kapareho ng pagsasagawa ng isang NOT gate o isang x na operasyon sa b,
at siyempre, ang pag-explore ng
isang bit b sa pamamagitan ng halaga 0 ay walang ginagawa rito, na kapareho ng pagsasagawa ng
identity na operasyon sa kanya.
At maaari nating ipahayag ang identity na operasyon bilang x sa kapangyarihan ng 0.
Kaya kung magsasagawa tayo ng isang Uf gate sa dalawang qubit sa standard basis
state na cat b tensor cat a,
makukuha natin ang resultang ito, ayon lamang sa kahulugan ng Uf gate.
at sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng formula, maaari nating isulat ang estado na iyon tulad ng makikita mo dito.
Ang formula na ito ay gumagana para sa lahat ng pagpipilian ng b, kaya sa pamamagitan ng linearity, gumagana ito
para sa isang arbitrary na estado na SI
sa halip na cat b.
At partikular, kung gusto natin, maaari tayong pumili ng SI na maging minus state.
At narito ang susi kung bakit nangyayari ang phase kickback
na penomenon.
Ito ay dahil ang x na operasyon
na inilapat sa minus state ay nagbibigay sa atin ng negatibong 1 beses ang minus state.
Sa mathematical na mga termino, sinasabi nating ang minus
state ay isang eigenvector ng x na operasyon, na may eigen value na katumbas ng negatibong 1.
Ang mga eigenvector at eigen value
ay kritikal na mahalaga sa linear algebra pati na rin
sa quantum information, at magkakaroon tayo ng marami pang
sasabihin tungkol sa mga ito
habang nagpapatuloy ang serye.
Pero sa ngayon, kailangan lang nating
ang simpleng formula na ito.
At gamit ito, maaari
nating gawing simple ang ating state vector.
At iyon doon ay essentially ang phase
kickback na penomenon na nakasulat bilang isang formula.
Gumagana ito dahil ang minus
state ay isang eigenvector ng NOT na operasyon na may
eigen value na negatibong isa.
Ipo-generalize natin ito sa isang
medyo malaking paraan sa Aralin 7, kapag lumipat tayo sa phase
estimation procedure, na siyang nagpapatakbo
ng Shor's factoring algorithm.
Maaari tayong makita ang formula na ito sa aksyon sa pagsusuri ng Deutsch's
algorithm tulad ng sumusunod.
Bago ang query gate, ang ating estado ay ang tensor product ng minus at plus na mga estado.
Pagkatapos ay inilalapat natin ang query gate, at ang pag-expand ng plus
state ay nagbibigay sa atin ng estado na ito.
Ngayon ay inilalapat natin ang phase kickback formula para makuha ang expression na ito, at pagkatapos ay nagpapatuloy ang pagsusuri
tulad ng dati.
Ito ay kapareho ng dati, pero dito tayo ay naglalagay lang ng
focus sa phase kickback para makilala natin ito
at maaari rin tayong maging handa para
rito kapag lumitaw ito muli.
Susunod na lilipat tayo sa
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, na isang extension
ng Deutsch's algorithm na talagang naglulutas ng ilang
iba't ibang query problem.
Ang kalamangan na
nagbibigay ang Deutsch's algorithm kumpara sa mga klasikal na algorithm
ay medyo maliit, isang query kumpara sa dalawa.
Ang Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm ay nagpapalaki ng kalamangan na iyon nang kaunti, at ipapaliwanag ko ang ibig sabihin ko
nito kapag nakarating na tayo doon.
Ang Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm ay maaaring ituring bilang isang natural at direktang paraan ng pagpapalawak ng Deutsch's algorithm
mula sa mga function mula sa isang bit patungo sa isang bit patungo sa mga function mula sa n bits patungo sa isang bit, o sa ibang salita, ang mga function ng anuring ito.
Bilang isang quantum circuit, ang Deutsch-Jozsa
algorithm ay mukhang ganito, at ito ay ating tatawaging Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
para lamang gumawa ng isang maliit na
pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng circuit na ito at ng Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm mismo dahil mayroon ding isang
klasikal na post-processing na hakbang.
Ang ideya ay kung tatakbo tayo
ng circuit na ito at pagkatapos ay susukat, makakakuha tayo ng ilang n bits string y
na nagsasabi sa atin ng isang bagay
tungkol sa function na f.
Sa puntong ito, sa pamamagitan ng paraan, hindi ko pa talagang sinabi
kung ano ang query problem na maaaring nating asahang
malutas sa circuit na ito, darating ito sa lalong madaling panahon.
Pero ang punto ay
sa pamamagitan ng pagpapatakbo ng circuit na ito, makakakuha tayo ng ilang impormasyon tungkol sa f na maaaring makatulong
sa atin na malutas ang mga query problem
kung saan ang f ay ang input. At tulad ng sinabi ko kanina, talagang maaari tayong gumamit ng circuit na ito
para malutas ang ilang
iba't ibang query problem.
Una, titingnan natin
ang query problem na kilala bilang ang Deutsch-Jozsa problem, na siyang problema na nilayon ng Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
na malutas sa una.
Ang Deutsch-Jozsa problem ay isang generalization ng Deutsch's problem, kung saan ang layunin ay matukoy kung ang isang ibinigay na function
ay constant o balanced.
Mapapansin na ito ay hindi ang natural na paraan para gawing generalize ang parity problem
sa mga function ng anuring ito.
Dito hindi tayo nag-co-compute ng parity, ang gawain ay mag-output ng 0 kung
ang function na f ay constant
at 1 kung ang function na f ay balanced.
Ang unang bagay na mapapansin tungkol sa
problemang ito ay na kapag ang n, ang bilang ng input bit sa
function na f, ay hindi bababa sa 2,
mayroong mga pagpipilian para sa function na hindi constant at hindi balanced.
Halimbawa, narito ang isang
function mula sa 2 bits patungo sa 1 bit na hindi constant at hindi balanced.
Hindi ito constant dahil parehong binary na halaga
ay lumilitaw sa mga output, at hindi ito balanced
dahil ang dalawang output value
ay lumilitaw nang iba't ibang frequency. Ang 0 ay lumilitaw nang tatlong beses
at ang 1 ay lumilitaw nang isang beses lamang.
Para maging balanced,
ang mga output na 0 at 1 ay kailangang lumitaw nang eksakto
ng parehong bilang ng beses.
Ang katotohanan na mayroong mga function na hindi constant at hindi balanced kapag ang n ay hindi bababa sa 2 ay okay lang, pero ito ay isinasaalang-alang lang natin bilang mga function na iyon
bilang mga "don't care" na input. Kaya sa ibang salita, ito
ay isang promise problem.
At narito ang isang tumpak
na pahayag ng problema.
Ipinangako sa atin na ang input function na f ay alinman constant o balanced, at ang layunin ay malaman
kung alin sa dalawa ito.
At hindi tayo responsable sa kung ano ang mangyayari kung ang input
ay hindi nakakatugon sa pangako.
Ang Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm,
na naglulutas ng problemang ito, ay una sa pagpapatakbo ng Deutsch-Jozsa circuit at pagkatapos ay nag-output ng 0
kung ang string na
nakuha natin mula sa mga measurement ay ang all-zero string
at nag-output ng 1 kung hindi.
Ang isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi nito ay nag-o-output tayo ng OR ng
mga bit na sinusukat natin.
Para suriin ang Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, magiging kapaki-pakinabang
na maglaan muna ng ilang sandali para isipin ang tungkol sa mga Hadamard gate.
Maaari nating, siyempre, ilarawan ang Hadamard
na operasyon bilang isang matrix, pero maaari rin nating ilarawan
ito sa mga tuntunin ng aksyon nito
sa mga standard basis state,
tulad ng makikita mo dito.
Ang dalawang equation na ito ay maaaring
pagsamahin sa isang solong equation, na naglalarawan kung paano
gumagana ang isang Hadamard na operasyon para sa a na maging alinman sa
dalawang binary na halaga,
at maaari tayong pumunta nang kaunti pa at ipahayag ang nakukuha natin
bilang isang sum tulad nito.
Gamit ang formula na iyon, maaari tayong bumuo ng isang formula na naglalarawan kung paano gumagana ang isang layer
ng mga Hadamard gate, kung saan maglalapat tayo ng isang Hadamard
gate sa bawat isa sa n qubit.
Dito nilalarawan natin ito
aksyon sa mga standard basis state.
At para maging malinaw tungkol sa notation, kapag sinulat natin ang h tensor n tulad nito, kung saan ang tensor n na bahagi ay isang superscript,
ibig sabihin nito ang n fold
tensor product ng H sa sarili nito, o sa ibang salita, n kopya
ng h na lahat ay tensor nang magkasama.
Inilalapat natin ang operasyong ito
sa isang standard basis state, at dito sumusunod ako sa
convention na ginagamit ng Qiskit
para i-index ang mga binary string, dahil magandang oras na
para ipakilala ang convention na iyon.
Kaya ang x0 ay isang bit, ang x1 ay isang bit,
at iba pa na may n bits sa kabuuan, at ang mga bit ay nakaorder tulad ng
makikita mo dito sa screen.
Maaari mong isipin ang paraan na ito
ng pag-index ng mga bit bilang katumbas ng kanilang significance kung titingnan natin ang mga string bilang
kumakatawan sa mga integer
sa binary notation, halimbawa.
Kung maglalapat tayo ng isang Hadamard gate
sa bawat isa sa mga qubit na ito, maaari nating ipahayag ang resulta bilang n fold tensor product
ng isang Hadamard gate na inilapat sa bawat qubit, at pagkatapos ay maaari nating ilapat ang ating formula sa bawat isa sa mga tensor factor.
At dito ginagamit natin ang
mga pangalan na y at minus 1 pababa sa y1 sa halip ng b sa formula,
kaya ang mga ito ay mga binary na halaga. At tinitiyak nating gumamit ng bagong pangalan sa tuwing ginagamit natin ang formula.
Kung pagkatapos ay i-expand natin ang lahat gamit ang multilinearity
ng mga tensor product, makukuha natin ang expression
na makikita mo dito.
At para maging malinaw, ang n sum ay pinagsasama
sa isang solong sum, pero pinagsasama pa rin natin ang lahat ng posibleng halaga
para sa mga indibidwal na binary na halaga.
Ngayon ay linisin natin ang mga bagay para makapunta tayo nang kaunti pa.
At ang susunod na hakbang ay
ipakilala ang isang bagong operasyon sa mga string na tinatawag na binary dot product.
Ito ay isang operasyon sa mga binary string na may parehong haba.
At ang binary dot product ng dalawang string x at y
ng parehong haba ay ang eXclusive OR o ang parity
ng mga produkto ng mga indibidwal na bit.
Maaari rin mong sabihin na ito ang XOR ng logical and ng mga indibidwal na bit, dahil ang and ay kapareho
ng produkto
para sa mga binary na halaga. Ang isa pang paraan para ilarawan
ito ay 1 o 0
depende sa kung
ang sum ng mga produkto ng mga indibidwal na bit ay gansal o pantay.
Ito ay maraming katulad sa isang inner product kung titingnan natin ang mga string
bilang mga vector ng binary na halaga, pero kung saan nag-co-compute tayo ng Modulo-2,
o sa ibang salita, kinukuha natin ang natitira pagkatapos ng paghahati sa 2.
Hindi ito talagang isang inner product, kaya nararapat na magbigay ng ibang pangalan sa kanya.
Sa kasong ito, maaari nating gamitin ang binary dot
product para gawing mas maigsi ang ating formula para sa aksyon ng isang layer ng Hadamard gate
sa mga standard basis state, at narito ito dito.
Ginagamit natin ang katotohanan na
dahil ang sum na ito dito ay lumalabas sa
exponent ng negatibong 1,
ang tanging mahalaga ay kung
ito ay pantay o gansal, pero kung hindi man, ito ay basically lamang isang condensed
na bersyon ng ating formula.
Sa pamamagitan ng paraan, ang binary
dot product ay symmetric sa kahulugang ang x dot
y at y dot x ay pantay,
kaya malaya tayong baguhin ang
ordering kung iyon ay kapaki-pakinabang.
At ngayon na mayroon na tayong formula na iyon, medyo madali na
suriin ang Deutsch-Jozsa circuit.
Magsisimula tayo sa n qubit sa 0 state at ang ibabang qubit sa 1 state, at magsasagawa tayo ng Hadamard
gate sa lahat ng mga ito.
Kaya ito ang estado ng
n + 1 qubit na nakuha natin.
Ino-treat natin ang
ibabang qubit nang hiwalay dahil iyon ay magiging maginhawa.
At muli, makikita nating nangyayari ang phase
kickback na penomenon.
Makukuha natin ang expression na ito
sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng ating formula, kung saan pinapalitan natin ang
all-zero string para sa x at pinapalitan ang x para sa y,
na binabanggit na ang binary dot
product ng all-zero string sa anumang string ay 0.
Pero maaari rin nating ipangaliwala ito nang direkta. Kinukuha natin ang tensor
product ng n plus state, at ito ang nakukuha natin,
tensor sa minus state. Pagkatapos ay inilalapat ang UF gate, at dito nangyayari ang phase
kickback na penomenon.
Ang halaga ng f ng x ay nai-XOR
sa minus state para sa bawat x sa sum.
Kaya ang f ng x ay na-kick sa phase.
Ngayon ay maglalapat tayo ng isa pa
layer ng Hadamard gate lamang sa tuktok na n qubit, at sa pagkakataong ito, talagang
kailangan natin ang formula.
At kapag inilapat natin ito at gumawa ng kaunti
lang na simplification, makukuha natin ang estado na ito dito.
Kaya iyon ang ating panghuling estado bago
ang mga measurement.
Ang estado ay mukhang medyo kumplikado, at mahirap itong gawing simple dahil hindi tayo talagang alam
ang anumang bagay tungkol sa function na f.
Pero tandaan, ang tanging
kailangan nating malaman ay kung lahat ng
measurement ay nagbibigay ng outcome na 0 o hindi,
dahil iyon ang nagtatakda kung ano ang ating sagot sa problema.
Kung makita natin na ang bawat
measurement outcome ay 0, nagtutulad tayo na ang function ay constant.
At kung alinman sa
measurement outcome ay 1, nagtutulad tayo na ang function ay balanced.
Kaya kalkulahin natin ang probability na makuha ang all-zero string
mula sa mga measurement.
At iyon ay nangangailangan na ang isang resulta na talagang madaling kalkulahin, dahil ang binary dot
product ng all-zero string
sa anumang string ay zero. Kung susuriin natin ang ating vector at
iniisip natin kung ano ang mangyayari kapag ang y ay ang all-zero string,
makukuha natin ang expression na ito dito para sa probability na makuha ang all-zero string
mula sa mga measurement.
At isinasaalang-alang ang dalawang posibleng kaso kung saan ang f ay constant at ang f ay balanced, nakikita natin na ang probability na
makuha ang all-zero string ay 1
sa kasong ang f ay constant, at zero kapag ang f ay balanced.
Kapag ang f ay constant, ang sum ay alinman sa 2 sa
n o negatibong 2 sa n, at ang paghahati sa dalawang to the n
at pagkuha ng absolute
value squared ay nagbubunga ng 1.
At kapag ang f ay balanced, ang sum ay katumbas ng 0.
Iyon ay dahil makakakuha tayo ng
positibong 1 at negatibong 1 nang pantay na bilang ng beses,
kaya lahat sila ay nagkakansela.
Kaya iyon na. Ang Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm
ay naglulutas ng Deutsch-Jozsa problem gamit ang isang solong query,
at walang error. Ipinagpapalagay na ang lahat ng operasyon
ay ginagawa nang perpekto, tama ito sa bawat solong pagkakataon.
Kaya paano ito ikinocompara sa
kung ano ang magagawa natin nang klasikal?
Buweno, kung ipinagpipilit natin ang isang
deterministic na algorithm na nakakakuha ng tamang sagot
sa bawat solong pagkakataon, kung gayon sa pinakamasamang kaso,
kailangan natin ng 2 sa n minus 1 plus 1 query, at iyon ay dahil kailangan nating i-query ang function
sa mahigit kalahati ng mga input nito para matiyak ang solusyon.
Kahit i-query natin ang function sa 2 sa n minus 1
iba't ibang input string, posible na makita natin ang parehong output value
sa bawat solong pagkakataon, at maaaring ito ay dahil
ang function ay constant, o maaaring talagang balanced ito
at napakasuwerte lang nating nakita ang parehong output
na halaga sa bawat solong pagkakataon.
Kaya iyon ay isang malaking kalamangan
ng quantum kumpara sa klasikal, isang solong query kumpara sa
exponentially na maraming query.
Gayunpaman, kung gagamit tayo ng isang
probabilistic na query algorithm at tinatanggap natin ang isang maliit na probability na ito ay sumasagot nang hindi tama,
kung gayon kailangan lang natin ng ilang query.
Partikular, kung
random na pipiliin natin ang k string at ie-evaluate ang function
sa mga random na string na iyon,
kung gayon malamang na malalaman natin ang tamang sagot.
Partikular, sumasagot tayo ng 0 o constant kapag nakakuha tayo ng parehong function
na halaga sa bawat solong pagkakataon at 1 o balanced
tuwing makakakita tayo ng dalawang
iba't ibang function na halaga.
Kung gagawin natin iyon, palagi tayong magiging tama kapag
ang function ay constant dahil, siyempre, palagi tayong makakakita ng parehong
output value sa kasong ito.
At kung ang f ay balanced, malamang na makakita tayo ng
dalawang iba't ibang output value.
Ang pagkakataon na hindi natin makita
ang parehong output value sa kasong ito ay kapareho ng pagkakataon na mayroon tayo ng pagtapon ng isang barya ng k beses
at pagkuha ng parehong
resulta sa bawat solong pagkakataon.
Kaya halimbawa, kung
itakda natin ang k na katumbas ng 11, ang probability ng pagkuha ng maling sagot ay mas mababa sa isang ikasampu ng isang porsyento.
Kaya lalo na kapag isinasaalang-alang natin ang katotohanan na ang mga quantum computer ay hindi kailanman magiging perpekto sa katotohanan, hindi talagang napakalaki ng kalamangan natin dito,
pero gumagawa tayo ng pag-unlad, at mayroon tayong isang quantifiable na kalamangan ng quantum kumpara sa klasikal na lumalampas sa Deutsch's algorithm.
Maaari rin nating gamitin ang Deutsch-Jozsa circuit para malutas ang ibang query problem na kilala bilang ang Bernstein-Vazirani problem.
Narito ang pahayag ng problemang iyon. Ang input ay isang function
mula sa n bits patungo sa 1 bit, tulad ng Deutsch-Jozsa problem,
at muli, ito ay isang promise problem.
Sa pagkakataong ito, ang pangako ay mayroong ilang n bits string s kung saan ang function na f
gumagana tulad ng makikita mo dito,
kung saan ang output ay ibinibigay
ng binary dot product ng input sa string s na ito,
at ang layunin ay simpleng
hanapin ang string s. Kaya maaari nating isipin na ang
string s ay nakatago sa ilang kahulugan,
pero maaari tayong matuto tungkol sa kanya
sa pamamagitan ng paggawa ng mga query sa f, at ang ating layunin ay hanapin
ang nakatagong string na ito.
Para maging malinaw, karamihan sa mga function
ay hindi nakakatugon sa pangakong ito, pero tulad ng karaniwan, nagmamalasakit lang tayo tungkol sa
mga input function na nakakatugon.
Kung tutuusin, ang Deutsch-Jozsa circuit ay talagang naglulutas ng problemang ito
nang wala pang pagproseso.
Kung tatakbuhin natin ito para sa isang
function tulad ng mayroon tayo dito na nakakatugon sa
pangako para sa ilang string s, ang mga measurement ay magpapakita ng string s
nang walang karagdagang post-processing na kinakailangan.
Kaya tingnan natin kung paano ito gumagana.
Nasuri na natin
ang Deutsch-Jozsa circuit, kaya maaari tayong
direktang pumunta sa dulo.
Narito ang expression na
mayroon tayo kanina para sa estado bago ang mga measurement, at ang expression na iyon ay
valid para sa anumang function na f.
At ngayon, kung ipinasok natin
kung ano ang ipinangako sa atin tungkol sa function na f at ginawang simple,
makukuha natin ang minus state
para sa ibabang qubit na naka-tensor sa cat s para sa tuktok na n qubit.
At kaya makukuha natin ang s kapag sumusukat tayo.
Mayroong kaunting trabaho na gagawin para maisagawa ang mga simplification
na ipinakita ko dito, at hindi ko ito daraanan sa video na ito,
pero mayroong mas maraming detalye tungkol sa kanya sa textbook na content para sa seryeng ito, na mahahanap mo sa pamamagitan ng pagsunod sa link sa paglalarawan ng video,
o subukan mo lang ito para sa iyong sarili para sa pagsasanay.
Kaya nakita natin na
ang Deutsch-Jozsa circuit ay naglulutas ng Bernstein-Vazirani
problem sa isang solong query.
Hindi masyadong mahirap ipakita
na ang anumang klasikal na algorithm, maging ito ay deterministic
o probabilistic, ay nangangailangan ng hindi bababa sa n query
para malutas ang Bernstein-Vazirani problem sa simpleng dahilan na kailangan natin ng n bits ng
impormasyon para mabawi ang s,
at ang bawat query ay nagbibigay sa atin ng hindi hihigit
sa 1 bit ng impormasyon.
Kaya nakakakuha tayo ng isa pang kalamangan ng quantum kumpara sa klasikal
na mga query algorithm, isang query para sa mga quantum algorithm,
n query para sa mga klasikal na algorithm.
Sulit na maglaan ng sandali para pag-usapan ang
nomenclature na ginagamit sa konteksto ng problemang ito at kaunti tungkol sa kasaysayan.
Minsan tinutukoy ng mga tao ang algorithm na inilarawan ko kanina bilang ang Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm, pero ito ay talagang ang
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit lamang,
at iyon ay isang bagay na, sa katunayan, malinaw na nakasaad sa gawa nina Bernstein at Vazirani.
Kaya medyo kakaiba na ito ay tinatawag na Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm dahil ito ay halos kapareho ng Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm
minus ang post-processing. Sina Bernstein at Vazirani ay, gayunpaman, pumunta nang isang hakbang pa.
Nagtatakda sila ng isang recursive
na bersyon ng problemang ito, kung saan kailangan mong basically
malutas ang mga instance ng Bernstein-Vazirani problem
para i-unlock ang mga bagong instance ng problema na nakaayos sa isang
kumplikadong tree-like na pattern.
Ito ay isang lubhang contrived na problema, pero ang punto ay sa pamamagitan ng
pagtatakda ng problema sa ganitong paraan, epektibo nilang napalawak
ang isa kumpara sa n query separation sa pagitan ng quantum at klasikal.
At ang nakuha nila ay
ang pinaka-unang kilalang halimbawa ng isang tinatawag na super polynomial na kalamangan ng quantum kumpara sa mga probabilistic na algorithm.
Ang recursive na bersyon ng
Bernstein-Vazirani problem na ito ay naging lubhang kawili-wili rin sa ibang pagkakataon sa computational complexity
theory para sa iba't ibang dahilan.
Anyway, ang punto ay na
sina Bernstein at Vazirani ay tiyak na nararapat sa pagkilala para sa kanilang mahahalagang kontribusyon,
pero hindi talagang
makatuwirang sumangguni rito bilang Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm, ito ay basically lamang ang
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm.
Sa huling bahagi ng aralin, titingnan natin ang isa pa
na quantum query algorithm na kilala bilang Simon's algorithm.
Makikita mo ang malinaw na pagkakatulad
sa pagitan ng algorithm na ito at ng Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, pero ito ay iba, at mas mahalaga,
nagpapakita ito ng mas malakas na kalamangan ng quantum kumpara sa klasikal
na mga query algorithm.
Partikular, nagbibigay ito sa atin ng isang
provable exponential na kalamangan ng quantum kumpara sa mga klasikal na algorithm, kahit ang mga probabilistic.
Ang problema na nilulutasan nito ay medyo artificial, at mahirap isipin ang isang sitwasyon kung saan ang paglutas nito
ay magiging kapaki-pakinabang,
pero ito ay direktang nagbigay-inspirasyon
sa pagdiskubre ni Peter Shor ng isang quantum algorithm
para sa integer factorization,
at iyon ay lubhang sumusuporta
sa ideyang ito ng query model bilang isang Petri dish kung saan maaaring mabuo ang mga quantum algorithmic
na ideya.
Magsimula tayo sa query problem na nilulutasan ng Simon's algorithm, na, tulad ng maaaring nang nahulaan mo,
ay tinatawag na Simon's problem.
Narito ang pahayag ng problema, at kailangan nating i-unpack ito para maunawaan kung tungkol saan ito.
Ang unang bagay na
mapapansin ay na sa pagkakataong ito, ang input function na f ay nag-map ng n
bits string patungo sa m bits string
kung saan ang m ay ilang positibong integer na hindi katumbas ng isa sa pangkalahatan.
Ito ay isang promise problem. At tulad ng Bernstein-Vazirani problem, ang pangako ay kinabibilangan ng ilang string s na maaari nating ituring bilang isang nakatagong string,
at gayundin tulad ng
Bernstein-Vazirani problem, ang layunin ay mag-output ng
nakatagong string s na ito.
Ang pangako ay mas
kumplikado sa pagkakataong ito, kaya hatiin natin ito at
unawain kung ano ang sinasabi nito.
Para magsimula, basahin lang natin ito. Sinasabi nito na mayroong isang string s na may haba na katumbas ng n
kung saan ang isang partikular na "if"
at "only if" na kondisyon ay totoo para sa lahat ng pagpipilian ng n bits string x at y.
Partikular, kailangang
maging totoo na ang f ng x ay katumbas ng f ng y kung at tanging kung ang isa sa
dalawang posibilidad ay mangyayari.
Ang unang posibilidad ay ang x ay katumbas ng y, at ang ikalawang posibilidad ay ang pagkuha ng
bitwise eXclusive OR ng x
sa nakatagong string s, makuha natin ang Y.
Ito ay naging isang
medyo mahigpit na pangako sa kahulugang karamihan
ng mga function ay hindi nakakatugon sa kanya.
Ilang napaka-espesyal na function lamang
ang nakakatugon sa kondisyong ito.
Ngayon, para mas maunawaan ang pangakong ito at samakatuwid ang problema mismo, isinasaalang-alang natin ang dalawang pangunahing kaso.
Ang unang kaso ay ang s
ay ang all-zero string.
Sa kasong ito, maaari nating gawing simple ang "if"
at "only if" na pahayag sa pangako dahil ang bitwise
eXclusive OR ng anumang string x
sa all-zero string
ay simpleng ang string x.
Kaya ang kondisyon ay nagiging simple
patungo sa f ng x ay katumbas ng f ng y kung at tanging kung ang x ay katumbas ng y.
At iyon ay isa lang pang paraan ng pagsasabi na ang f ay isang one to one na function.
Sa ibang salita, ang string na f ng x ay kailangang natatangi
para sa bawat posibleng string x.
Kaya kung ang f ay isang one to one na function, kung gayon ang pangako ay talagang nakakatugon, partikular para sa s na maging
ang all-zero string,
at sa kasong ito, iyon ang
tamang output.
Ang ikalawang kaso ay ang s
ay hindi ang all-zero string, at ang implikasyon nito ay ang function na f ay kailangang two to one.
Kaya para sa bawat input string x, mayroong eksakto isang pang string na ang f ay nag-map sa parehong
string na ang x ay nag-map,
at bukod pa rito, ang isa pang string
ay kailangang ang string na nakuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng bitwise
eXclusive OR ng x kasama ang s.
Ang isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi nito
ay na ang bawat n bit string x ay may isang kasosyo, at ang kasosyo na iyon ay ang string na nakuha natin
sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng bitwise eXclusive OR kasama ang s.
Ang anumang dalawang kasosyo ay kailangang magbigay
sa atin ng parehong output string kung i-plug natin ang mga ito sa f, at walang ibang string ang pinapahintulutang magbigay sa atin
ng parehong output string na iyon.
Kaya ang mga ito ay necessarily magkaibang string na nagagawa ng mga kasosyo.
Narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang function tulad nito na inilarawan sa pamamagitan ng talahanayan ng mga halaga nito.
Kaya ito ay isang function
mula sa 3 bits patungo sa 5 bits.
Kung titingnan natin ang talahanayan
ng mga halaga na ito nang matagal, makikita nating ang pangako ay
nakakatugon para sa string 011.
Ang 000 at 011 ay mga kasosyo. Ang pag-XOR ng alinman sa kanila
ng s ay nagbibigay sa atin ng isa pa,
at kumukuha sila ng parehong output value, na siyang 10011 sa partikular na kasong ito, at walang ibang string ang gumagawa
ng parehong output string.
Ang 001 at 010 ay mga kasosyo dahil ang pag-XOR ng alinman
ng isa ng s ay nagbibigay ng isa pa, at gumagawa sila ng parehong output value,
na muli, ay hindi ginagawa
ng anumang ibang string.
At ang sitwasyon ay
katulad para sa 100 at 111 pati na rin para sa 101 at 110.
Kaya kung ang input sa
problema ay ang function na ito, ang tamang sagot ay ang string 011.
Tulad ng sinabi ko kanina, karamihan sa mga function ay hindi nakakatugon sa pangakong ito, ito ay isang napaka-tiyak na kondisyon.
Dapat ding mapansin na
kung ang pangako ay nakakatugon, maaari lamang itong matugunan para sa isang string s.
Kaya palagi lang may isang
tamang sagot sa problemang ito.
Kaya iyon ang Simon's problem. Tulad ng sinabi ko, mahirap isipin ang isang praktikal na sitwasyon kung saan gugustuhin mong malutas ang problemang ito,
pero hindi iyon ang punto. Ang punto ay subukan na malaman kung saan magaling ang mga quantum computer, at lumalabas na mas superior sila
sa mga klasikal na algorithm para sa
paglulutas ng partikular na problemang ito.
Ngayon titingnan natin
ang Simon's algorithm, na naglulutas ng Simon's problem.
Ang algorithm ay binubuo ng
pagpapatakbo ng quantum circuit na makikita mo dito ng ilang beses, kasunod ng isang klasikal
na post-processing na hakbang,
at magiging mas tiyak tayo tungkol sa kung ano ang ibig sabihin ng ilang
beses sa ibang pagkakataon.
Ang circuit ay halos katulad
ng Deutsch-Jozsa circuit, sa pagkakataong ito dahil ang function
na f ay nag-map ng n bits patungo sa m bits,
ang query gate ay iba. Sa halip na isang solong
qubit sa ibaba, mayroon na tayong m qubit sa ibaba
at n sa itaas tulad ng dati.
Ang isang pangunahing pagkakaiba ay hindi tayo
nagtatayo ng minus state o maraming minus state sa ibaba.
Ang mga ibabang qubit na ito ay lahat
ini-initialize sa 0 state, at ang mga estado ay direktang
pumupunta sa query gate.
Kaya walang phase kickback na kasangkot sa algorithm na ito, hindi lang ganoon ang paraan ng paggana nito.
Bukod sa mga pagkakaibang
binanggit ko, gayunpaman, ito ay halos katulad ng
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit.
Maglalapat tayo ng isang layer ng Hadamard gate, pagkatapos ay maglalapat tayo ng isang query gate nang isang beses, at pagkatapos ay maglalapat ng isa pang
layer ng Hadamard gate
kasunod ng mga standard basis measurement ng tuktok na n qubit.
Ang ideya ay ang bawat beses na tatakbuhin natin
ang circuit na ito at susukat, makakakuha tayo ng ilang string y na nagsasabi sa atin ng isang bagay
tungkol sa nakatagong string s
sa Simon's problem. At sa pamamagitan ng pagpapatakbo ng circuit
nang ilang beses nang nakapag-iisa, makakalipas tayo ng sapat na
statistical na katibayan tungkol sa s
para malaman kung ano
ito nang may mataas na kumpiyansa.
Ngayon suriin natin ang quantum
circuit para sa Simon's algorithm para makita kung ano ang ginagawa nito.
Ang estado pagkatapos ng unang
layer ng Hadamard gate ay ganito, katulad ng mayroon natin para sa
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm.
Maliban sa pagkakataong ito, ang ibabang m qubit ay lahat sa 0 state
kaysa sa mga minus state.
Pagkatapos maisagawa ang query gate, nakikita natin na ang halaga ng f ng x ay naisulat sa
ibabang o pinakakaliwang m qubit,
at iyon ay dahil ang f ng x ay na-XOR sa all-zero string.
Kaya muli, walang phase kickback na nangyayari sa algorithm na ito.
Pagkatapos ay isasagawa natin ang ikalawang
layer ng Hadamard gate.
At gamit ang parehong formula tulad ng dati para sa aksyon ng isang
layer ng Hadamard gate sa isang standard basis
state, cat x sa kasong ito,
tulad ng nasa orihinal na formula, makukuha natin ang estado na ito dito, kung saan ang aksyon ng mga Hadamard gate
ay naging mas malinaw. Pero kung gusto natin, maaari rin nating isulat ang estado
sa isang mas compact na anyo tulad ng mayroon natin dito.
Sa puntong ito, sinusukat natin ang tuktok na n qubit para makakuha ng ilang end bit string y, at kailangan lang nating malaman
kung ano ang mga probability
para sa iba't ibang string. At iyon ay makakatulong sa atin na maunawaan
kung anong impormasyon ang nakukuha natin mula sa string y tungkol sa string s
na nakatago sa loob ng function na f.
Kailangan natin ng
kaunti pang espasyo para dito, at hindi na talagang kailangan natin
ng circuit diagram, kaya alisin natin ito at magbigay ng mas
maraming espasyo para sa pagsusuri.
Narito ang estado bago
ang mga measurement, na siyang mga standard basis measurement ng tuktok o pinaakananang n qubit.
Kaya ang measurement
ay katumbas ng ikalawang cat.
Tukuyin natin ng p ng y, ang probability na ang mga measurement ay nagbibigay sa atin ng string y para sa bawat posibleng y.
At kung susundin natin ang mga panuntunan mula sa Aralin 2, makukuha natin na ang bawat isa sa mga probability na ito ay ang Euclidean norm squared ng anumang vector na naka-tensor
sa standard basis state,
na katumbas ng kung bakit sa
ating quantum state vector.
Nagbibigay iyon sa atin ng expression na ito dito.
Ngayon, para mas mahawakan ang
mga probability na ito, kailangan nating gumamit
ng ilang notation, at maaaring pamilyar ka na sa notation na ito
dahil ito ay medyo karaniwang ginagamit sa matematika.
Una, kapag tinutukoy natin ang
range ng function na f, ibig sabihin lang natin ang set ng lahat ng mga string na maaaring lumabas mula sa function na ito.
Kaya ito ang set ng lahat ng f ng x na sumasaklaw sa lahat ng posibleng
pagpipilian ng isang input string x.
Pangalawa, gagamitin natin ang notation na ito na makikita mo dito para mangahulugang ang set ng lahat ng input string x
na ang f ay nag-map sa isang ibinigay na string z, para sa anumang pagpipilian ng
z na gusto nating isaalang-alang.
Medyo mukhang tulad ng
inverse ng function na f, pero hindi ito talagang inverse dahil ang f ay hindi necessarily invertible.
Nakikita rin natin na mayroon tayong
isang set bilang argumento sa kaliwang kamay, at sa kasong ito, ito ang set na naglalaman
ng isang string z lamang,
at iyon ang pahiwatig na kailangan natin para makilala na hindi tayo nag-uusap tungkol sa
inverse ng function na f, ito ay tinatawag na pre-image.
Ang pre-image ay maaaring
tukuyin nang mas pangkalahatan para sa anumang set na ibinigay bilang argumento, hindi lang ang set na naglalaman
ng isang solong elemento,
pero ito lang ang kailangan natin. Hindi ito ang pinakamabuting
notation sa mundo dahil madaling
mapagkamalan ito sa inverse,
pero sapat na ito
at malawakang ginagamit, kaya gagamitin natin ito.
At ngayon kung gagamit tayo ng notation na ito, maaari nating muling isulat ang vector na kinukuha natin ang
Euclidean norm squared para makuha ang probability para sa
pagsukat ng bawat string y.
Ginagawa natin ito dahil kailangan nating makita
kung ano ang mga coefficient para sa bawat indibidwal na standard basis state, at hindi iyon malinaw mula sa
expression na ito dito,
dahil, sa pangkalahatan, maaaring mayroon tayong maraming pagpipilian ng x na nagbibigay sa atin ng parehong string na f ng x.
Sa esensya, ang ginagawa lang natin
ay ang pag-split ng sum sa x sa pamamagitan ng una na pag-sum sa lahat ng
z sa range ng f,
at pagkatapos sa loob ng sum na iyon, pag-sum sa lahat ng x sa pre-image ng z, o para maging mas tumpak,
ang pre-image ng set
na naglalaman ng string z.
Nagpapahintulot iyon sa atin na palitan ang f ng x ng z sa loob ng cat dito.
At ang sum sa lahat ng iba't ibang string
x na ang f ay nag-map sa bawat z ay kinokolekta sa
coefficient para sa bawat cat.
Basically ay naglalagay tayo ng mga string sa mga bin, nag-su-sum sa mga bin, at pagkatapos nag-su-sum sa mga string sa bawat bin,
pero katumbas iyon ng simpleng
pag-sum sa lahat ng mga string.
Kaya nakakakuha tayo ng isang expression na katumbas ng
isa na sinimulan natin,
at ngayon ay maaari nating kalkulahin ang
Euclidean norm squared.
Ito ay ang sum ng mga parisukat ng absolute value
ng mga coefficient, at kaya, nakukuha natin ang expression na ito dito
para sa ating mga probability.
Siyempre, magbigay ng oras sa iyong sarili
para i-verify ito, kung gugustuhin mong gawin iyon, tumatagal ng oras para masanay sa lahat nito
at para magawa
ang mga kalkulasyong ito, at habang mas maraming pagsasanay ang ibinibigay mo sa iyong sarili, mas magiging madali ito.
Sa ngayon, hindi pa natin talagang
ginagamit ang pangako sa Simon's problem.
Ang ating pagsusuri ng mga probability na ito ay talagang gumagana para sa anumang function na f, pero ngayon ay oras na para isipin ang tungkol sa Simon's
problem nang partikular.
Hahati-hatiin natin ang mga bagay sa parehong dalawang kaso
na mayroon tayo kanina.
Ang unang kaso ay ang s
ay ang all-zero string, at ang ikalawang kaso ay ang
s ay hindi ang all-zero string.
Sa unang kaso, na
ang s ay ang all-zero string, ang mga bagay ay medyo simple.
Sa kasong ito, tulad ng nakita natin kanina, ang f ay isang one to one na function, kaya mayroong isang solong string x
na nai-map sa bawat isa sa mga
string z sa range ng f.
Nagagawa nitong ang absolute value squared ng sum sa mga string na iyon ay katumbas ng 1 dahil mayroon lang isang
solong termino sa sum,
ito ay alinman sa plus 1 o minus 1, pero hindi mahalaga kung alin dahil kinukuha natin ang
absolute value squared, at kaya makukuha natin ang isa.
Mayroon 2 sa n
na elemento sa range ng f, at alam natin iyon dahil ang f ay one to one, kaya mayroong isang string sa
range para sa bawat input string.
At kung ie-evaluate natin ang buong expression, makikita natin na ang bawat string y ay lumilitaw nang may probability
na isa sa dalawang to the n.
Kaya sa ibang salita, ang
mga measurement ay nagbibigay sa atin ng isang string y na pinili nang random na pantay-pantay.
Maaaring hindi iyon mukhang kapaki-pakinabang, pero maaari nating, sa katunayan, makilala ang pag-uugaling ito mula sa pag-uugali na nakukuha natin sa kaso
na ang s ay hindi ang all-zero string, at makikita natin kung paano ito gumagana sa ilang sandali.
Para ngayon, gayunpaman, simpleng napapansin lang natin na kung
ang f ay nakakatugon sa pangako sa Simon's problem sa kasong ang s ay ang all-zero string,
kung gayon ang resulta ng mga measurement ay isang uniform random string.
Ngayon ay lumipat tayo sa ikalawang kaso, na ang pangako
ay nakakatugon para sa isang string s na hindi ang all zero-string.
Sa kasong ito, tulad ng napag-usapan natin kanina, ang bawat string z sa range ng f ay may eksakto dalawang string na nag-map rito,
dahil ang bawat string ay may isang kasosyo, at ang bawat pares ng kasosyo
ay nag-map sa ilang natatanging string, at partikular, ang kasosyo ng bawat string
ay ang string na nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-XOR kasama ang s.
Kaya kung pipiliin natin ang anumang string
z sa range ng f, at bibigyan natin ng pangalang w ang alinman sa mga
string na ang f ay nag-map sa z,
kung gayon ang XOR ng w kasama ang s ay ang
isa pang string na nag-map sa z.
Titingnan lang ang isang termino sa ating sum na katumbas ng anumang string z sa range na naiisip natin,
nakikita natin na maaari
nating isulat ito nang mas malinaw tulad ng mayroon natin dito.
Mayroon tayong dalawang string sa pre-image ng z, w at w na nai-XOR kasama ang s.
Kaya maaari nating isulat ang sum
tulad ng makikita mo sa screen, at ngayon ang magagawa natin ay ang mag-pull ng isang factor ng
negatibong 1 sa kapangyarihan ng w.y.
Ang factor na iyon ay magiging
alinman sa plus 1 o minus 1, kaya nawawala ito kapag
kinukuha natin ang absolute value,
at ang natitirang sa atin ay
ang expression na ito dito.
Ang mga detalye ay hindi lahat ipinakita dito, at hindi necessarily
malinaw na gumagana ito sa ganitong paraan, pero maaari mong suriin na ang dalawang expression na ito ay pantay
sa pamamagitan ng pagbabalik sa kahulugan
ng binary dot product at pag-iisip tungkol sa kung ano ang nangyayari kapag ang mga bagay na ito ay nasa
exponent ng negatibong 1,
hindi malayo sa kung ano ang mayroon natin para sa
Bernstein-Vazirani problem.
Sa wakas, maaari nating hatiin ang
expression na ito sa dalawang kaso.
Ito ay 4 kapag ang binary dot
product ng s at y ay 0, at ito ay 0 kapag ang binary
dot product ng s at y ay 1.
Mapapansin nang partikular na
walang dependency dito sa w o z, depende lang ito sa s at y.
Ang dahilan na nangyayari ito ay
dahil sa napaka-tiyak at espesyal na kalikasan ng pangako.
Sa esensya, iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ang pangako ay binuo sa ganitong paraan, para lahat ay magtrabaho tulad nito.
Muli, ang bawat string ay may isang kasosyo, na nakukuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-XOR kasama ang
nakatagong string s na ito,
at iyon ang nagpapaganap sa lahat ng ito.
Maaari na tayong bumalik sa
expression para sa mga probability at ipasok ang mga bagay.
Kapag ang s ay hindi ang all-zero string, mayroon 2 sa n minus 1
na elemento sa range ng f,
na siyang kalahati ng
bilang ng mga input string, at ang pag-plug ng mga halagang kalkula natin ay nagbibigay ng formula na ito dito.
Kaya sa pagkakataong ito, ang y ay hindi isang
ganap na random na string, kundi ang y ay uniform sa eksakto kalahati ng n bit string,
at partikular, ito ay
uniform sa mga string na may binary dot
product na katumbas ng 0 kasama ang s.
Ngayon na alam na natin kung paano gumagana ang circuit
para sa Simon's algorithm at partikular kung ano
ang mga probability para sa iba't ibang measurement outcome,
nananatiling ipaliwanag kung paano ito nakakatulong sa atin na malutas ang Simon's problem.
Buod ng natutunan natin, kung ang function na f ay nakakatugon sa pangako sa Simon's problem,
kapag ang nakatagong string s
ay ang all-zero string, nakakakuha tayo ng ganap na random
na string mula sa mga measurement,
kung saan ang bawat end bit string
y ay pantay na malamang.
Kung sa kabilang banda naman, ang function na f ay nakakatugon sa pangako para sa ibang string s, isa na hindi katumbas
ng all-zero string,
kung gayon makakakuha tayo ng isang random string y na may binary dot product
na katumbas ng 0 kasama ang s, at sa lahat ng mga string na iyon,
ang bawat y ay pantay na malamang.
Pero hindi tayo makakakuha ng isang string y na may binary dot product
na katumbas ng 1 kasama ang s.
Ang tanong ay nagiging, "Sapat ba ang impormasyong ito
para matukoy ang s?" At ang sagot, tulad ng
iminungkahi ko na, ay oo,
basta tatakbuhin natin ang
circuit nang sapat na beses.
Partikular, ipalagay natin
na tatakbuhin natin ang circuit ng k beses, kung saan ang K ay katumbas ng n plus r,
kung saan ang r ay ilang numero na
magkokontrol ng
posibilidad na mabawi natin ang s.
Bilang isang halimbawa lang, kung
pipiliin natin ang r na maging 10, magiging matagumpay tayo nang may
probability na higit sa 99.9%,
kaya hindi natin kailangan ang r na maging napakalaki.
Sa pangkalahatan, ang probability ng kabiguan ay mas mababa kaysa sa probability
ng pagtapon ng isang patas na barya ng r beses at pagkuha ng ulo sa bawat solong pagkakataon.
Kaya kung hindi sapat ang 99.9%, kung gayon itakda ang r na maging 20, at ang pagkakataon ng kabiguan ay
mas mababa sa isa sa isang milyon,
o pumili ng anumang r
na nagpaparamdam sa iyo ng ginhawa. Hindi mo maaaring maggarantiya ng tamang solusyon, pero maaari mong gawing negligible
ang probability ng error
para sa lahat ng praktikal na layunin.
Dito ay pinapangalanan natin ang mga
string na ito na y1 hanggang yk, kung saan ginagamit natin ang mga superscript para matulungan tayong pangalanan ang mga string na ito,
para masanggunian natin ang mga subscript para sumangguni sa mga indibidwal
na bit ng mga string na iyon.
Kaya ang mga ito ay hindi mga exponent
o anumang bagay na tulad nito, ang mga ito ay ang mga pangalan lang na ibinibigay natin sa k string na ito.
Ang bawat isa ay may haba n dahil nakuha natin ang mga ito
mula sa pagpapatakbo ng circuit para sa Simon's algorithm.
Kaya maaari nating isulat ang
mga indibidwal na bit ng k string na ito tulad ng makikita mo dito.
Ang gagawin natin ngayon ay gumawa ng isang matrix m, kung saan ang bawat entry ng matrix na ito ay isang bit, at nakukuha natin ang mga bit na ito mula sa mga string
na sinukat lang natin, tulad ng ipinakita dito.
Kaya ang matrix na ito ay may k row at n column, at ang lahat ng entry nito ay mga binary na halaga.
Ngayon, hindi natin alam kung ano ang s. Iyon ang sinisikap nating hanapin, pero isipin lang nating sandali na alam natin ito,
at bumuo tayo ng isang column
vector mula sa mga bit ng s, tulad ng ipinakita dito.
Kung i-multiply natin ang vector na iyon ng m at pagkatapos ay kunin ang resulta modulo-2, o ang isa pang paraan ng pagsasabi nito
ay pinapalitan natin ang addition
ng eXclusive OR, kung gayon kailangan nating
makuha ang all-zero vector.
Iyon ay dahil ang bawat isa sa mga
entry sa resultang vector na ito ay wala itong iba
kundi ang binary dot product ng s
kasama ang isa sa mga row ng m.
Kung ang S ay ang all-zero string, palagi tayong makakakuha ng zero vector mula sa binary dot product.
At kung ang s ay hindi ang all-zero string, makukuha natin ito mula sa alam natin
tungkol sa mga probability para lumitaw ang mga string na y1 hanggang yk.
Partikular, ang
binary dot product kasama ang s ay palaging zero para sa lahat ng string na ito.
Isang simpleng paraan ng pagsasabi nito ay ang vector na ito
na binuo mula sa mga bit ng s ay palaging nasa null
space ng matrix m,
ipinagpapalagay na ginagawa natin ang lahat ng
ating aritmetika modulo-2, pero siyempre, hindi natin alam kung ano ang s,
sinisikap nating hanapin ang s.
Pero ang magagawa natin ay maaari tayong kalkulahin ang
null space ng matrix m na ito, muli, modulo-2.
Partikular, maaari nating gawin iyon gamit ang pamamaraan ng
Gaussian elimination, na siyang pamamaraang madalas itinturong
sa mga panimula na kurso sa linear algebra.
Gumagana ito nang perpekto kapag ginagawa natin ang lahat ng ating aritmetika modulo-2, at maaari itong gawin nang medyo
mahusay gamit ang isang computer.
At kung kalkulahin natin ang null space ng m, na binibigyan ng partikular na paraan na ang k string na ito ay
random na napili,
mababawi natin ang s nang may probability na higit sa
1 minus 2 sa negatibong r.
Para maging tiyak, ang makikita natin nang may probability na higit sa
1 minus 2 sa negatibong r ay ang null space
na kinabibilangan ng all-zero vector,
tulad ng palagi nitong ginagawa para sa bawat matrix, pati na rin ang vector na katumbas ng s, maging ito ang all-zero vector o hindi.
At pinakamahalaga, walang ibang vector ang
lilitaw sa null space.
Hindi talaga masyadong mahirap patunayan ito, bagaman hindi ko ito daraanan nang detalyado.
Ang ideya ay kung mayroon tayong ibang string na hindi ang all-zero
vector at hindi ito s, kung gayon ang bawat isa sa mga random
na string na y1 hanggang yk,
ay basically
magtatapon nito mula sa null space nang may probability na kalahati.
Kaya pagkatapos ng k shot, hindi malamang na mabubuhay ito, at sa katunayan, wala sa mga
string na hindi nabibilang
ang malamang na mabubuhay. At isang napakasimpleng katotohanan
mula sa probability theory, na kilala bilang union bound, ay maaaring
gamitin para maitatag iyon.
Hindi ko naipaliwanag ang lahat
ng mga detalye dito, pero sana ay naiintindihan mo ang ideya na sa pamamagitan ng pag-compute ng null
space modulo-2 ng matrix m na ito,
malamang na mababawi natin ang s, at ganoon nalalutas ng Simon's algorithm
ang Simon's problem.
May isang bagay pa lang
na sasabihin tungkol sa Simon's problem, at ito ay tungkol sa klasikal
na kahirapan ng problemang ito,
ibig sabihin, ilang query ang kailangan ng isang klasikal na query algorithm para malutas ang Simon's problem?
Ang sagot ay, marami, sa pangkalahatan.
Mayroong iba't ibang tumpak
na mga pahayag na maaaring gawin tungkol sa klasikal
na kahirapan ng problemang ito, at narito lang ang isa sa kanila.
Kung mayroon tayong anumang probabilistic
na query algorithm at ang algorithm na iyon ay gumagawa ng mas mababa sa 2 sa kapangyarihan ng n sa 2
minus 1, minus 1 query,
kaya ang bilang ng mga query na
exponential sa n, kung gayon ang algorithm na iyon ay mabibigo
na malutas ang Simon's problem,
nang may probability na hindi bababa sa kalahati.
Minsan, ang pagpapatunay ng
mga imposibilidad na resulta tulad nito ay maaaring maging napakahirap, pero ang isang ito ay hindi masyadong mahirap patunayan
sa pamamagitan ng isang elementary
na probabilistic na pagsusuri.
Hindi ko gagawin iyon sa aralin sa video na ito, at magtutuon lang ako sa halip
sa intuisyon sa likod nito.
Sinisikap nating hanapin ang nakatagong string s, pero hangga't hindi tayo nag-que-query ng function sa dalawang string na may
parehong output value,
makakakuha tayo ng napaka-limitado
na impormasyon tungkol sa s.
Basically, natututo lang tayo na
ang nakatagong string s ay hindi ang eXclusive OR ng anumang dalawang magkaibang
string na na-query na natin,
At kung mag-que-query tayo ng function sa mas mababa sa bilang ng mga query na ito, mayroon pa ring maraming pagpipilian ng s
na hindi pa naaalis.
Hindi ito isang pormal na patunay,
pero iyon ang pangunahing ideya.
Kaya sa buod, ang Simon's algorithm ay nagbibigay sa atin ng isang kapansin-pansing kalamangan ng quantum kumpara sa mga klasikal
na algorithm sa loob ng query model.
Partikular, ang Simon's
algorithm ay naglulutas ng Simon's problem nang may bilang ng mga query na linear sa bilang ng input
bit n sa ating function,
habang ang anumang klasikal na algorithm,
kahit na ito ay probabilistic, ay kailangang gumawa ng bilang ng
mga query na exponential sa n
para malutas ang Simon's problem nang may makatwirang probability ng tagumpay.
Totoo na ang Simon's problem ay medyo artificial na problema na malamang na walang sinuman
talagang gustong malutas,
pero iyon ang pangalawa. Minsan kailangan munang mabuo ang mga ideya bago ilagay sa pagsasanay.
At tunay, malinaw na sinabi ni Peter Shor na ang Simon's algorithm ang nagbigay-inspirasyon sa kanya sa ngayon
sikat na quantum algorithm niya
para sa integer factorization, na makikita natin sa ilang aralin.
At iyon ang katapusan ng Aralin 5.
Sa araling ito, tinitingnan natin ang
query model of computation, at nakita natin ang isang progresyon ng mga halimbawa
ng mga quantum algorithm
na nagpapakita ng mga kalamangan kumpara sa mga klasikal na algorithm
sa loob ng modelong ito.
Mayroon nga, sa katunayan, mas maraming alam
tungkol sa query model at mga quantum algorithm para sa iba pang mga problema na
hindi ko napag-usapan.
Kaya kung nakikita mong
kawili-wili ang modelong ito, mayroon pang marami
na matuttunan tungkol sa kanya.
Ang ating susunod na hakbang ay lilipat
palayo mula sa query model at patungo sa isang modelo ng kalkulasyon
na mas kumakatawan
sa uri ng mga problema na maaaring nating asahang malutas sa practice.
Umaasa akong sasama ka sa akin para sa Aralin 6, kung saan ang pangunahing pokus natin ay ang pagtatayo ng isang pundasyon para sa pag-aaral ng mga quantum algorithm.
At mula doon, lilipat tayo sa ilang
partikular na quantum algorithm, kabilang ang Shor's algorithm
para sa integer factorization
sa mga susunod na aralin. Paalam hanggang sa muli!